I was making six figures I'm not even
making but $16 working a big box retail
now and it's extremely stressful so I'm
a financial wreck 58 no savings don't
even have I can't even pay my bills how
much debt do you guys have 47,000 20 of
that is two Parent Plus Loans I want you
to have a hard conversation with your
kids and let them know I signed these
Parent Plus Loans I can't pay my bills
to eat
and I want you to tell them this is
embarrassing this is hard this is scary
whatever words you want to
use but that you need them to help with
the cost of their college education at
least for the foreseeable
future and they might tell you forget
you Mom we're not doing that whatever
you're right I signed my name on it and
if you want to watch your mom drown then
you can watch that but I need some help